in this video I'll talk about
inflammatory responses now whenever you
are bitten by an ant or a nail is poking
your skin you would feel a injury
now that injury could cause inflammation
the characteristic signatures for
inflammation is pain swelling redness
and warmth in the local region so these
are the key features of inflammation so
let me tell you inflammation
though it is painful and it it's itchy
sometimes but inflammation is a defense
response it is good for your body it's a
response by which your body alarms the
immune system to take over and to fight
the insult so definitely the
inflammation is a defense response so
let's just draw a portion of the skin
here we have the epidermis dermis and
the hypodermis and below that there are
blood vessels capillaries etc
innervating all over the skin so for a
simplicity purpose the capillary is
blown up and drawn like a big chunk now
let's say a nail a rusty nail and enrapt
by several pathogens and etc has entered
your some part of your skin as a result
several bacterias associated with that
has invaded now this situation is very
comparable to the border is broken so
the nail is poking your skin that means
the border your first line of defense is
broken and let's say these bacterias are
comparable with terrorists which come
when the fence is broken in a country so
they cross the border now we know in a
country there are patrolling police
officers that are always patrolling the
border area looking for potential
invaders and terrorists like that so in
body those patrolling police officers
are basically macrophages and dendritic
cells which roam around the
beneath the skin looking for potential
pathogens or targets which they can
phagocytose so whenever a pathogen is is
entering the body the generating cell or
the macrophages would first try to
recognize what is associated with the
pathogen so they would recognize
so-called pathogen associated molecular
patterns by their toll-like receptors on
their surface and they would immediately
secreting inflammatory mediators
especially the inflammatory cytokines of
il-1 and I le and sometimes also TNF
alpha now apart from that they would
also secrete chemokines these chemokines
are chemo attractants which would
attract further other macrophages into
that area so it works like a backup
signal as if the dendritic cell or the
macrophage is calling for backup
it would help or call in other
macrophages which are residing other
part of the body would come to that
local side of infection or local side of
innervation where they can fight and
combat the situation better now these
inflammatory mediators which would call
in other macrophages and dendritic cell
into the location of invasion now not
only that the dendritic cell would
engulf the pathogen then it would queue
up the pathogen and display some of its
antigens onto a class 2 antigen
presented see molecule because these are
classical antigen presenting molecule
cells they also mobilize to the lymph
node in the lymph node which is like an
army barak it would present that antigen
to t and the B cell they are by leading
to T and P cell activation
so this is very much comparable that
this patrolling police officer has gone
to the army base and interacting with
the Army's telling them about the
invasion situation and all so that is
how the adaptive immune system could be
also activated by these patrolling
police officer cells that mean the
dendritic
the macrophages now but what happens
just locally we would look at that so we
know that neutrophil also have
phagocytic activity but neutrophils are
hovering around inside the blood
capillaries near that so it turns out
post-injury wherever there is innovation
neutrophils come out from the blood
capital capillary to the tissue level
tissue level and they try to engulf the
pathogens but how does that happen and
why does not neutrophil always come out
in the tissue space and stay there it
the reason is the blood capital
capillary is tight all the time they
don't allow the neutrophil to move out
but by a process known as extravasation
the neutrophils monocytes etcetera these
blood cells can cross the blood vessel
and reach the tissue space where they
would differentiate into specific immune
effector cells now here is a picture
which shows that the neutrophils
basophils the monocytes are all over
around in the blood vessel now when
there is a inflammation the capillary
endothelial cells starts expressing
specific adhesion molecules this
adhesion interaction between the
neutrophils or any other white blood
cells and these addition molecules on
the capillary endothelial cells slow
them down as a result they are now
immobilized at the same time due to
several other inflammatory mediators
cytokines histamines etcetera would
increase the permeability of these
endothelial cells and leaving gaps
between the capillary endothelial cells
as a result the neutrophil can easily be
squeezed out from that capillary and can
enter the tissue space this process is
known as lymphocyte extra possession
once they're in the cap
broke out of the capillary and in the
tissue space neutrophils mass cells etc
candy granulate also basophils as well
they candy granulate and secret
histamine and many other inflammatory
mediators like prostaglandin and etc so
which would further peso dilate or make
the blood capillaries more dilate along
with these immune cells fluids also leak
out from this capillary that causes our
temporary swelling but all these
responses that the body is generating
after these pathogen innervation is a
defense response an alarm response now
the immune system is more alarmed about
the fact that there is an innovation
happened in somewhere of the body and
they're sending reinforcements to that
places so as a summary of the
inflammatory response
so the inflammatory response would start
with tissue injury some insect bite or
anything and the primary response is
phagocytosis of those pathogens by
macrophages or dendritic cell the long
time response is sending out
inflammatory signals that is a calling
for backup and also make taking out more
neutrophils neutrophils monocytes etc
into the tissue space such that they can
combat the situation together so that is
how inflammatory response though it
sometimes could be highly painful and
itchy they help the body to fight
against pathogens so if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe thank
you